Judd good morning how are you I'm very
well good morning uh what did the Mets
mean to you growing up well that was the
only sport i followed other than tennis
I was into Borg I like my Borg I didn't
like when McEnroe suddenly came up and
started beating up on Borg but I used to
go to Mets games i was born in 67 my dad
took me to the you know the play often
say it was at 72 or 73 and then they
were just terrible for you know about
eight years they just had a really bad
run and I loved it I loved going to it
to Shea Stadium when there was 5,000
people in the 50,000 seat stadium I love
liking a team that was losing and then
you know Darryl and enjoy could and came
to the Mets in the early 80s and they
started getting good at it couldn't have
been more exciting what your
sensibilities of looking for humor or
scripts that have humor in it I know
that diminishes you it you know you're
somebody who knows a good story and
telling a good story but it is that what
you were looking at when you did this
documentary that it this isn't knocked
up or bridesmaid or anchorman this is
something different yeah I didn't really
think thinking through to be honest with
you I met my code director Michael
bonfiglio when I did this show
iconoclasts it was about me and Lena
Dunham and I thought wow this guy's
really child to be fun to try to do a
documentary with him and then one day I
was just tweeting 230-430 hey great show
last night and someone tweeted back hey
you want to do one and it without even
thinking I said yeah be great to do what
about Dwight Gooden and Darryl
Strawberry that would be a great story
I'd love to know more about that having
not thought about it at all and then
they just put it together really quickly
I didn't even know this story well when
I mentioned it I just had had read
you know some of my goodness book and
they'd seen a lot of his appearance
talking about it it seemed fascinating
toughest moments in doing the
documentary what that what were the
toughest moments all right well I didn't
do the interviews because I'm such a fan
I don't think I would have had the
courage to really go there and like
partner such a genius what was difficult
about conceding and putting it together
was just figuring out where to spend
your time there were so many incidents
in their lives you could have done an
entire documentary on their childhoods
before they got to the Mets you could
have done a documentary about any of the
times that they crashed so just try to
figure out how to space it out and which
ones to put in and which ones to leave
out was difficult and because they're
all very serious I mean there's you know
intense moments where they make terrible
mistakes and they do all require some
time do you learn more about good nurse
strawberry well I think that
strawberries is a little bit more
forthcoming he's very into the rehab
world he he runs to rehabs his whole
life is about sobriety and helping
people get sober so I think he's in a
much more open place you know which is
just all about sharing your experiences
is it strange or how strange was it to
come out of something like this where
you're watching it and it's and it's not
uplifting you don't leave with a smile
on your face like people normally would
when they're watching your movies it's
very weird we did premiere in New York
it was funny to have something with only
a few laughs it's very serious it's
about addiction it's about we know how
addiction really destroys people's lives
and then when it adds people are like I
was really good but usually show a movie
everyone laughing and giggling and oh my
god that happens to me all the time and
and this was a very different type of
conversation after but I think an
important one and I enjoyed you know
creating something with Michael that you
made people talk about you know what
it's like to be young
and be under this kind of pressure
what's it like to be in New York in the
80s when you could have everything and
there's no TMZ there's no one paying
attention and and how much trouble you
can get yourself into and then what it
takes to try to survive and then to get
yourself sober but I also wonder judge
if if we had social media back in the
80s would that have been a better thing
for good and in strawberry that maybe we
would have seen it earlier because you
know with Doc and covering that meds
team I didn't know that you know he was
you know abusing you know cocaine or
strawberry we had an idea but I had no
idea what was going on there and maybe
social media would have brought that to
the forefront a little bit earlier oh
absolutely i mean remember years ago
Chris Rock said to me could you imagine
if they had all this when Frank Sinatra
was around whatever Jerry Lewis was
doing and Richard Pryor I mean it really
was a different here and they stayed in
the documentary they said I think Darryl
said ab you know you would go out and do
whatever you wanted to do and no one
would ever find out just true until you
completely crashed but but and it also
felt like there wasn't much supervision
that the world of baseball and the Mets
you know they weren't saying hey guys
you gotta stop a big trouble I seem to
be an environment in that era that
allowed that in a way that I don't think
would be tolerated for a second today
he's Judd Apatow co-directed ESPN's
latest 30 for 30 documentary doc and
Daryl that arrow airs tonight at nine
Eastern on the mothership how did you
know when did you know that LeBron James
could act well he was really funny
hosting Saturday Night Live and that's
pretty rare usually the athletes come on
in there stiff Peyton Manning was
hysterical hosting Saturday that I'm and
so it happens so when Amy wrote the
movie she didn't know any athletes she
just the only name she knew was LeBron
James so I think she kind of tempted in
you know it's like writing babe Rufus
your script
and then bill hader said oh he's a
really good guy he was he was nice when
he did Saturday Night Live so it was one
of those weird situations where everyone
in LeBrons world was very cool and
really open to hearing about it and then
today let's all sit down and then we all
have lunch and then LeBron just totally
got the joke you know we just said
here's the joke of your character how we
would write you this like bizarro LeBron
which is it how you act at all but we'll
just create a persona for you and he
laughed his ass off the difference you
really got it the difference in seeing
somebody who's funny in person at a
dinner table stand up comedy or somebody
who is funny on on film or TV it is
there a separation there that some are
just better at looking funnier or
sounding funnier when it's on TV or in a
movie as opposed to stand up and being
an actor being able to do it oh
absolutely there are people that are
just so funny to talk to and if you ask
them to do something scripted they
completely lock up like me you can't act
at all John just that a little thing of
a movie james franco directed if they
showed it to me and i thought i was i
was pretty good it'll be 20 25 years to
figure out how to do with 90 second
theme what's the movie that had the most
impact on your comedy growing up I I
think diner the Barry Levinson movie was
one because it really was about
friendship and growing up and the way
people actually talk and it had those
great those great scenes about sports
hair he was testing his fiancee that he
wouldn't marry her unless she knew
everything about sports the Baltimore
Colts yes it was just a great idea and
had so many great actors and fast times
at ridgemont high I thought you know was
you know who they really captured what
it felt like to be in high school a lot
of cameron crowe's work like say
anything and and what James Brooks was
doing
uh you know terms of endearment and
broadcast news you know I like when
people can be real but also hilarious so
they're not acting fake they're not
broad it's what they're like in life but
then the movie finds a way to be both
dramatic and really funny simultaneously
but you like dialogue then it's it's not
the sight gag as much as it is the
dialogue that kind of leads I mean
certainly yeah you know diners say
anything I mean it's all about what we
remember those lines and a lot of times
you can just have a sight gag and you
remember the sight gag not necessarily
the dialogue yeah I'm not really the
visual guy Maddie I used to love Buster
Keaton music as a kid but my brain
doesn't really work that way I
collaborated with Adam Sandler at Robert
Smigel on you don't mess with the zohan
but i have to say smile read both of
those jokes he's Judd Apatow you can
watch tonight it's doc and Daryl airs at
nine Eastern on the mothership it's the
30 for 30 documentary Judd thanks for
joining us we appreciate it good luck
with this all right pleasure the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience